what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we we got ourselves an official trailer
for a movie I cannot wait to see in the cinemas
on the big screen and that is from the Glorious
man himself our Saints the man who is solely
responsible for saving movie theaters Thomas the
Cruise's Mission Impossible seven dead reckoning
part one John good morning how are you I am the
gold standard sir leave a like for John's gold
standard capabilities that would be awesome also
I gotta ask you guys a question why have you
not picked yourself up a real rejects exclusive
space baby's t-shirt thank you to everyone who has
gone ahead and purchased one hope your bodies are
feeling joyful I hope Serendipity has reached
your soul now that you have yourself a real
rejects exclusive shopsteredition.com t-shirt
also over there we got a bunch of exclusive
apparel it's one of the best ways to support the
channel but what are the best ways to support your
epidermis in total Link in description box
and pin comment let's check this trailer out
our lives it is for the sum of our choices [Music]
Ronnie cannot escape the pass run time
Ethan the submission of yours
is impossible it's not a costume
chilly
truth is Vanishing whoa
it's been a long time you've no idea the power I
represents oh it knows your story
and How It Ends so much running
listen to me the world's coming after you
activity
if anything happens to them there's no place
that I won't go to kill you that is written
I'm gonna go off this Cliff yeah
Kelly you're all going to kill you
Ethan what's your objective
someone's writing ultimate objective
who's to accept it oh sweetie
all the way back to the start
none of our Lives can matter More
Than This Mission I don't accept that
yeah
Tom Cruise Tom's sword fight
the train
[Music]
more chilly I'm like you I felt the most like
John Wick to me it really means you're out in the
desert and stuff like that they're globetrotting
well just a lot of the locations of some of the
Noir Aesthetics to it the personal Peril that
you could feel in the emotional undertones and
the wide Ensemble but it's just kind of funny
that we had like John Wick 4 which became like
this epic Ensemble action Masterpiece and then
now we're getting like the mission impossible
version of it because they're they they feel
like totally different franchises but you can
find like similarities you can then you could
also kind of say the same thing about Keanu
Reeves and and uh Tom Cruise but you know like
Tom Cruise really does do all of his own stunts
where's Keanu Reeves really loves to credit
his stunt double for for a lot of this genres
even really credits Tom Cruise and all of these
movies are decided over bottles of whiskey no
this was like a really really awesome trailer
I feel like they're reserving a lot for the
the actual movie itself even though you know we
still got to see a bunch of different shots and
locations and all that kind of fun [__] here too
but this was bringing back to me was a lot of that
kind of personal emotional intensity that I love
so much about Mission Impossible 3. there seems
to be a lot of Espionage elements from the first
mission impossible as well that seems sort of like
littered through like throughout this trailer not
just bringing back the kitchen into the fold not
just bringing him back there's and even the uh
the the thing with the Train on top of it which
excited me because you know whenever I re-watched
the first mission impossible I do have the [__]
off my brain like how cool would it be if Tom
Cruise decided to just redo that but do it like
really yeah now with his full full uh Ascension
to stunt God yeah because while there was some
like real stunts to be had with that whole train
sequence you know there's a lot more green screen
Reliance heavy there it is knowing who Tom Cruise
is today I wonder if they decided no we're really
really going to do the train [__] but we're
gonna keep it real this time you gotta hide some
of that with green screen right like he's just
impossible to do all that practical I don't know
I I don't know crazy because you got another actor
involved in this sequence here and just due to the
factor our moving train I have a hard time wrap my
head around that they could do it practical either
way it does feel like an homage to the first one
yeah I think it's really smart that they're just
leading mostly with you know the globe trotting
Stakes the action the stunts things like that I
mean we know that the Ensemble is capable and I
like too that we have the new characters like we
see glimpses of all the actors who are joining
the cast but you know they're really leaving
the surprise and the joy of discovering how they
all tie in and uh you know for the experience of
the movie and I think with a sequel that seems to
want to hearken back to the very first mission for
Ethan Hunt Tom Cruise that's a nice thing because
now it's going to get people going back revisiting
the first one in preparation for this and two
I know one thing I think Christopher mcquarie
said was that they wanted to like his goal with
this was to take like the emotional Arc that has
you know developed for Ethan Hunt over time and
give just as equal amount of character growth
and TLC into the entire ensemble basically give
everybody some kind of distinct Arc and some sort
of like really climactic sort of character Stakes
along with the world-rending mission and that's
something I think will be really cool too if
they can nail it because like they've built such
a great Ensemble over time and uh and yeah to see
them all kind of hey I have some kind of emotional
uh underpinning alongside all the awesomeness is
just a cool Prospect and something that yeah if
you're going to do a two-part potential send-off
I think that makes a lot of sense too because you
know you get the stunt goodness everybody can
sink their teeth into the acting and then if we
you know make a billion trillion dollars we can
keep it going yeah of course yeah yeah I love so
much about this trailer uh because of the fact of
how intense it actually feels women Galore in here
Palm Clementi of joining the cast and then you
got Vanessa Kirby you got Haley Atwell Rebecca
Ferguson is what I was trying to pull right there
I wonder if Monahan will make an appearance yeah
Michelle Bishop gets handy Newton back in The
Fray as well and Maggie Q definitely bring all
the women back Paula Patton just get them honors
some other woman at the beginning here too it
looks like some personal death yeah yeah yeah
totally yeah we're going back to what you're
saying about Christopher Corey that guy has a
history with screenwriting that it farce surpasses
you know cool action movies so you know like his
his Mastery of craft when it comes to character
development and psychological uh attention
and turmoil it seems like we're going to be
getting more of that this time around which I'm
also very excited for ladies and gentlemen what
did you think about this Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part one trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like we
will certainly be doing a review right out of the
theater for this one when it comes out let's do
a patron of the day shout out Brandon Benzie your
mission should you choose to accept it is to jump
from a moving train and report back all right you
are here to test the movie Magic for us all right
is Tom Cruise full of it or is he the real deal
or are you the gold standard I think it's easy to
say that at least you of all of us have to be the
gold standard you've got the perfect comic book
alliteration in your name and if there was ever
somebody I would be to entrust an impossible
mission too with the most likelihood of success
it would be you Brandon you are strong you are
solid as a rock and I know that when uh you know
the when the S hits the F you are not going to
turn you're not gonna be a mole or a rat or any
kind of animal poorly associated with impossible
missions and Espionage so uh yeah buddy go out
and test those stunts and let us know what to
expect from the realism of mi7 part one part two
to follow anyway I love you buddy stay pledged and
that's the that's the real way to save the world
you say things in these shout outs [Music]